tour
tour en seré c'est vachement
beauin des qui se baladent à l'intérieur
dans les dans les arbres verts c'est
superbe pas faire peur aux
animaux joli ça hein prends le plein CRE
tu vois prends pas la route sur le
attends on prend le c bien que que les
arbres que le attends juste un plan l'AR
pour qu'elle puisse monter un truc quand
même non non mais tu peux le monter
pareil mais sans prendre la route tu
vois prendre le marché
voilà voilà c'est plus joli
tu veux bouge un peu pour fa ou faire
bouger un peu le plan tu
voas des des trucs enfermé les animau
c'est super
beau lumière al
c'est descendre un peu fr j'père qu'
soit un
peu so un peu ha
là
tu vois là nous on vibre mais la caméra
vibre pas avant vibrait génial génial
sur des points comme ça je fa ma main à
couper quoi je suis d'accord c'est
carrément le H bien ça c'est le H qui
fout la merde reg regarde de les deux
mal doucement doucement doucement les
deux mal en train de se
charcuter VO de deux quoi il y a deux
mal en train de se
battre de Bou en train de se taper
dessus c'est
rigolo regz regardez regardez ah ils ont
fini
merde vasy fix un peu s'il te plaît
oua il se
ah c'est trop
drôle prends les toil les gros paquets
de de d'animaux je
termine on restant dans ce cadre là tu
es bien là tu en bouant là-dedans c'est
beau ça continu de balader làdedans
peutre
en pour le tenir excuse-moi il y a un
arbre avec un carré avec des gambesieux
tu le vois le carré avec
s voilà là si pouit rester là par là
prendre c'est
génial au milieu du bordel c'est un
espèce de carré assez
joli allez
coupe
toi allez c'est
parti quand tu j tu montes un vers le
haut c'est génial tu laisses dans le
coin c'est beau c'est très beau ça voilà
monte un peu monte un peu
voilà doucement doucement
doucement pas mal
ça-
penses